Jake Tapper asked some other
hard-hitting questions to the elderly
man pretending to be president he asked
him about our recession or not recession
or is it a recession midterm elections
are four weeks from today the economy
remains top top of mind for voters J.P
Morgan Chase CEO said the U.S is likely
to enter a recession in the next nine
months Bank of America says the U.S
could start losing 175 000 jobs a month
gas prices are on the rise again
should the American people prepare for a
recession no look they've been saying
this now how every every six months they
say this every six months they look down
the next six months and see what's going
to happen it hadn't happened yet it
hadn't been there there has there is no
there's no guarantee that they're going
to be I don't think there will be a
recession if it is it'll be a very
slight recession that is we'll move down
slightly we'll look think about what's
happened we have done more we're in a
better position than any other major
country in the world economically and
politically we are we still have real
problems but we look look what we got
done we we passed so much legislation
that significantly makes a makes a point
about you know for example the American
Rescue plan the legislation to deal with
inflation the the inflation act we moved
along I mean there's so much that's been
accomplished that the idea that there's
not something there's an automaticity to
a recession it's just not it's just not
there they keep they've been predicting
this off and on for the last but you
just said that a slight recession is
possible so it is possible look it's
possible I don't anticipate it
oh he doesn't anticipate it much like
treasury secretary Janet Yellen hoped we
weren't going to be in a recession okay
so technically so first off everything
he said there is nonsense every single
thing he said there is nonsense or a
confusion or obfuscation of the truth
first off we technically are in a
recession right now A recession by every
definition until the last month was two
negative quarters back-to-back quarters
of reduction in the GDP we've already
hit that tomorrow we will find out if it
is a third quarter so we're already in
one whether he calls it a little one or
a tiny one or a teeny tiny little bitty
recession we are still in a recession it
just is and then he talks about you know
it's funny he called it the inflation
act he forgot to say reduction it was
called the inflation reduction act but
he actually was kind of honest there in
his muddled nonsense it's the inflation
act because the inflation reduction act
which was just the government spending a
[ __ ] ton of money to devalue the dollar
thus pushing us further into a recession
everyone knows this and this is one of
those things you don't need a high level
analyst to tell you that things are not
going well with the economy all you have
to do is try to buy a product and see
how long it takes and how much it costs
and our gas prices high and all of these
things like there are basic truths that
you can figure out without a lot of uh
you know Poli SCI going into it